the tennis player novak djokovic has  arrived back in the country after being  deported from australia because he was  not vaccinated against covert 19 which  has ended his hopes of defending his  australian open title  he stopped over in dubai on the way a  touchdown of belgrade and  he was expecting to receive something of  a hero's welcome he has overwhelming  support in his native country of course  his family uh still living there and the  serbian president accused the australian  government over the weekend of harassing  the top-ranked tennis star and urged him  to return home where he would be  welcomed i'm sure a lot of those people  there are media but an awful lot of them  are his supporters some speculation over  whether he may enter a career in  politics in the country after his tennis  career ends but for now he won't be  defending his grand slam title in  australia